From NPR, this is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Vivek Murthy was seven years old when his mom woke him up one night, long after he'd gone to sleep. She rushed him and his sister into their car. I remember piling back into the back seat and my sister was sleepy sitting next to me. Vivek's parents, who were immigrants from India, ran a medical practice in Miami. His dad was a physician. As they reached through the night in the car, my parents told me that their patient, Gordon, had just died after a long struggle with a sadic cancer. And we were driving to a trailer park in Miami where Gordon lived, because my parents were worried that his widow Ruth
来自NPR，这里是隐藏的大脑，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。维韦克·穆尔蒂七岁时，有一天半夜被妈妈从睡梦中叫醒。她带着他和姐姐匆匆上了车。我记得自己又挤回了后座，姐姐睡眼惺忪地坐在我旁边。维韦克的父母是从印度来的移民，在迈阿密经营一家诊所。他的父亲是一名内科医生。当我们在夜色中开车前行时，我父母告诉我，他们的病人戈登在与一种残酷的癌症长期搏击后刚刚去世。我们正开车前往戈登居住的迈阿密的一个拖车公园，因为我的父母担心他的遗孀露丝
would be grieving alone. And to this day, I will never forget, like the image of my mother in her traditional sorry, standing on the steps of that trailer, illuminated by the moonlight, and embracing Gordon's wife Ruth as they both cried and cried. And in that moment, you know, it struck me that there are, their lives were so different, Ruth's and my mother's. But in that moment they were family, like not
会孤单悲伤。直到今天，我永远不会忘记母亲穿着传统的纱丽，站在那个拖车台阶上的情景，月光洒在她身上，她拥抱了戈登的妻子露丝，两人放声大哭。你知道，那一刻我突然意识到，露丝和我母亲的生活是多么不同。但在那一刻，她们是一家人，不是那种命中注定的家人，而是那种你为自己选择的家人。维韦克现在自己也是一名医生。他亲身体验过守候在生病患者病床前、安慰垂死之人家属的感受。有一个教训一直留在他的心中，那是他七岁时在那个夜晚学到的。在只剩下生命中最有意义的片段的最后时刻，真正凸显出来的是我们的人际连接。这就是我们在生命尽头获得的清晰认知。
the kind of family that's chosen for you, but the kind that you choose for yourself. Vivek is now a physician himself. He has experienced what it's like to be at the bedside of sick patients to comfort the families of the dying. One lesson that has stayed with him is something he learned at night when he was seven. In the final moments when only the most meaningful strands of life remain, it's really our human connections that rise to the top. That's the clarity that we get at the end of life.
生命之光。但正是我的父母从小就教导我，我们不必等到生命快结束时，才去认识和践行连接的力量。本周的“隐藏的大脑”节目将探讨人际关系的重要性、孤独的危害，以及我们如何才能过上联系更紧密的生活。在维韦克·穆尔蒂目睹父母安慰一位去世病人的悲伤遗孀多年之后，他离开迈阿密去追求自己的医学事业。这段旅程带他去了波士顿和康涅狄格州的纽黑文。2014年，他搬到华盛顿特区担任新职务：美国外科医生总长。根据他在担任外科医生总长期间的经历，
of life. But it was my parents who taught me from the earliest ages that we don't have to wait until the end of life in order to recognize and act on the power of connection. This week on Hidden Brain, the importance of relationships, the hazards of loneliness, and how we can all live more connected lives. Many years after the night when Vivek Muthi watched his parents comfort the grieving widow of a patient who had died, he left Miami to pursue his own medical career. That journey took him to Boston and New Haven, Connecticut. In 2014, he moved to Washington, DC for a new role. Surgeon General of the United States. Based on what he learned as Surgeon General,
他写了一本关于一个往往被忽视的重大公共卫生问题的书。这本书书名叫《在一起：有时孤独的世界中人类连接的治愈力量》。维韦克·穆尔蒂，欢迎来到“隐藏的大脑”。非常感谢，香卡。很高兴能和你在一起。每当我想到外科医生总长这个职位时，维韦克，我就会想到该办公室发布的关于吸烟与健康或应对阿片类药物危机的著名报告。在你担任外科医生总长不久后，你开启了一场针对
he's written a book about a major public health problem that is often hidden from view. The book is titled, Together, the healing power of human connection in a sometimes lonely world. Vivek Muthi, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks so much, Shankar. it's good to be with you. When I think of the office of the Surgeon General Vivek, I think about famous reports that have come out of that office about smoking and health or dealing with the opioid crisis. Shortly after you became Surgeon General, you went on a listening tour of the
美国的聆听之旅，你听到的故事促使你开始思考一个备受关注较少的问题。例如，你在俄克拉荷马城写道，你遇到了一对刚因阿片类药物过量失去儿子的夫妇。他们对你说了什么，维韦克？在俄克拉荷马州，我从那对夫妇那里听到的话是，在他们的儿子因阿片类药物过量去世后，他们很善良地跟我交谈。他们告诉我，多年来一直住在他们附近的邻居，在困难时期总是会过来，比如他们失业或生病时，
United States and the stories you heard prompted you to think of an issue that has received much less attention. In Oklahoma City, for example, you write that you met a couple who had just lost a son to an opioid overdose. What did they tell you, Evac? In Oklahoma, what I heard from the couple that was kind enough to speak to me after the death of their son, due to an opioid overdose, they told me that their neighbors, who had lived near them for years and years and years, had always come by during difficult times, when they lost a job or got sick,
他们会送来食物，顺道坐坐看看他们过得怎么样。但当他们的儿子去世时，没有人过来，这让他们感到非常惊讶。后来他们意识到没有人来，是因为他们觉得这对父母可能会感到尴尬，因为他们的儿子死于一种所谓的“不光彩的疾病”。
they had brought over food, had stopped by just to sit with them and see how they were doing. But when their son died, nobody came over, and they were really surprised by this. Later they realized that no one came because they thought that the parents may be embarrassed because their sons died of a quote unquote shameful disease.
因此，正当这对父母承受着因失去儿子而带来的巨大痛苦时，他们也面临着深深的孤独，因为他们身边没有了以往的爱与支持的源泉。密歇根州弗林特市也发生了非常相似的事情，人们告诉你，他们担心供水安全，但除了健康和环境问题之外，
And so at this time that these parents were dealing with an extraordinary amount of pain due to the loss of their son, they were also confronted with a deep loneliness because they didn't have their usual sources of love and support around them. So something very similar happened in Flint, Michigan, where people told you they were worried about the safety of their water supply, but besides the health and the environmental issues,
他们还在遭受一个根本上属于情感的问题。维韦克，那是什么？也正遭受着一个根本上属于情感的问题。维韦克，那是什么？我在弗林特水危机最严重的时候遇到的许多人都感到被抛弃。他们觉得没有人照顾他们。他们觉得被政府抛弃了。他们觉得被全国各地的人抛弃了，在新闻循环结束很久之后，甚至在铅污染问题在他们社区持续存在之后，这些人似乎已经对弗林特置之不理并向前看了。
they were also suffering from a problem that was fundamentally emotional. What was that Vivek? also suffering from a problem that was fundamentally emotional. What was that with it? Many of the people that I met in Flint at the height of the water crisis felt abandoned. They felt that there was nobody looking out for them. They felt abandoned by government. They felt abandoned by people around the country who they felt had perhaps turned their back on Flint and moved on, long after the new cycle had completed, but even after the problem of lead contamination persisted in their communities.
因此，在一个急需帮助的时刻，当弗林特许多父母因为自己允许孩子中毒而感到内疚时——尽管这并不是他们的错——他们发现自己只能孤军奋战来对抗这个问题。在这个时期，你还在波士顿和纳什维尔与同为医生的同行、护士以及其他医护人员交谈。许多人向你讲述了医护人员经常经历的职业倦怠。但当你倾听他们的故事时，你也察觉到了一种潜藏的暗流。你听到了什么？
And so at a time of great need, when many of these parents in Flint were feeling guilty about the fact that they had allowed their children to be poisoned, even though it wasn't their fault, they found themselves battling that problem all by themselves. You were also talking during this time with your fellow doctors and with nurses and other healthcare workers in Boston and Nashville. And many people were telling you about the burnout that healthcare workers often experience. But as you listen to their stories, you also picked up an undecorrent of something else. What did you hear?
嗯，关于医学界同行的经历，最让我感兴趣的是，我们当中有许多人作为群体度过了医学院和住院医师培训期，不是作为一个小组或同班同学，也不是和我们在医院里一起培训的住院医师。但在培训结束后不久，大家都各奔东西，最后他们大多觉得自己是在独自工作。因此我发现，许多同事都在这种被孤立的感觉中挣扎。
Well, it was so interesting to me about the experience of colleagues in medicine was that so many of us went through medical school and residency training as part of a group, not a group or a classmate, or the residents that we trained with in the hospital. But shortly after training, everyone scatters to the wind and they end up feeling largely like they're working alone. And so I found that many of my colleagues were struggling with this sense of being isolated.
他们不一定会说自己在与孤独搏击，但他们使用的词汇、经常说出的短语——比如这样的话：“我觉得自己是在独自处理所有这些问题。”“我觉得自己是可以被替代的，没有人真正认可我是谁。”“我觉得在这个系统中我们是隐形的。”这些一次又一次地向我传达，这些医生觉得他们只是独自一人在工作，试图照顾病人。他们对此感到沮丧。
They didn't necessarily say that they were struggling with loneliness, but the words that they used, the phrases that they uttered so often, this phrase is like, I feel like I'm dealing with all of these problems on my own. I feel like I'm interchangeable and that nobody recognizes me for who I am. I feel like we're invisible in this system. These all convey to me again and again and again, that these doctors felt that they were just them working alone, trying to take care of patients. And they felt frustrated by this.
我认为这加剧了他们许多人正在经历的职业倦怠。显而易见，你在俄克拉荷马城听到的、在弗林特听到的以及从同行医生那里听到的话之间存在着一种联系。所有这些对话中都贯穿着一个潜台词。有没有那么一瞬间，你突然意识到所有这些想法中贯穿着一个共同的主题，然后你说，你知道吗，我们在这里处理的事情实际上真的非常非常大？嗯，香卡，对我来说，这是一个逐渐认识到的过程，其中许多故事共同的主题
And I think it contributed to the burnout that many of them are experiencing. So there's a connection here obviously between what you heard in Oklahoma City and what you heard in Flint and what you were hearing from your physician colleagues. There's a subtext that runs through all these conversations. Was there a moment when you sort of realized that there was a common theme that ran through all of these ideas that you said, you know, what we're dealing with here is actually really, really big. Well, Shankar, it was a gradual recognition for me that the common theme in so many of these
实际上就是孤独。起初，当我听到这些故事时，在前几次甚至前五到十次对话中，我并没有把所有的碎片拼凑在一起。但在路上的每一天结束时，在经历了整整一天一夜的会议后，我会回到酒店房间，花一点时间反思我所听到的一切。一次又一次，浮出水面的都是这些围绕着孤立感、人们感到孤立无援以及感到隐形的对话。通过这次聆听之旅并倾听我全美各地对话中的孤独感，这段经历让我意识到，孤独的经历远比我意识到的要普遍得多。
stories was, in fact, loneliness. And initially, when I heard these stories, I didn't put all the pieces together for the first couple conversations or even the first five or ten. But at the end of each day when I was on the road, I would go back to my hotel room after a full day and night's worth of meetings, and I would just take a little time to reflect on what I had heard. And time and time again, what bubbled to the top, where these conversations around isolation and people feeling all alone and feeling invisible. That experience of going on this listening tour and hearing the loneliness in conversations that I was having all across the country helped me realize that the experience of Lonely Nose was far far more common than I had realized.
凯撒家庭基金会2018年的一项调查发现，美国22%的成年人饱受慢性孤独的困扰，这个数字超过了吸烟或患糖尿病的人数。苦于这种孤独的人似乎患心血管疾病、痴呆症、睡眠碎片化和抑郁症的风险更高。这样的例子还有很多。更孤独的人甚至寿命更短。因此，杨百翰大学的朱莉安·霍尔特-伦斯特德所做的研究表明，孤独与寿命缩短之间存在关联，
A 2018 survey by the Kaiser Family Foundation found that 22% of adults in the United States struggle with chronic loneliness, that's more than the number who smoke or who have diabetes. People who struggle with such loneliness seem to have a greater risk of cardiovascular disease, dementia, fragmented sleep and depression. The list goes on. Lonelyer people may even live shorter lives. So studies done by Julianne Holt-Lunsted from Brigham Young University have demonstrated that there is an association between loneliness
而缩短的程度或对死亡率的影响似乎类似于一天抽15支烟，甚至比肥胖或久坐生活方式对死亡率的影响还要大。我经常思考这个问题，因为作为外科医生总长，我和我的前辈们在演讲、报告和其他类型的活动中花了大量时间来解决吸烟、肥胖和久坐生活方式的问题。然而，直到我听到来自全国各地的这些故事并深入研究相关研究之前，我从未想过孤独可能是一个同样具有挑战性的健康威胁问题，同样需要得到解决。
and a shortening of the lifespan, and the amount of shortening or the mortality impact seems to be similar to smoking 15 cigarettes a day and even greater than the mortality impact that you see from obesity or sedentary living. I think about this often because as a surgeon general, I and my predecessors spent a significant amount of time in terms of speeches, reports, of time in terms of speeches, reports, and other kinds of campaigns addressing the issues of smoking and obesity and sedentary living. Yet it had not occurred to me until I heard these stories from around the country and
书中所讲的一个关于你称之为拉杰什的家庭朋友的个人故事让我非常感动。请给我讲讲拉杰什是如何进入你们家庭生活的，以及他身上发生了什么。拉杰什是来自印度的亲戚，在生活稍晚些时候来到美国，大概是在他五十多岁，五十岁出头的时候。他也是一个非常害羞的人。
delve into the research that perhaps loneliness was an equally challenging issue that was a threat to our health that also needed to be addressed. I was very moved by a personal story you told in the book about a family friend that you call Rajesh. A picture of me of how Rajesh came into your family's life and what happened to him. So Rajesh was a relative from India who came over a little bit later in life when he was perhaps in his 50s, early 50s. And he was also a very shy person.
我记得他刚来的前几个月一直住在我们家。他和我经常一起散步，绕着我们正在施工的地方走，当时我们正在翻新房子以增加一些空间。关于拉杰什，有趣的是，他也是个受过专业培训的工程师，所以他对正在进行的建筑工程很着迷。我们绕着建筑工地散步时，往往也是我听到他说最多话的时候。
I remember him staying at our house for the first few months after he came. He and I would spend time walking around where we were having construction done, renovating the house to add in a little more space. It was interesting about Rajesh. He was also, he also an engineer by training, so he was fascinated by the construction that was happening. And those walks that we would take around the construction site were when I would often hear him speak the most.
他会跟我讲正在浇筑的混凝土、正在架设的桁架，以及建造房屋可以使用的不同类型的建筑结构。直到多年后，当我意识到拉杰什是多么孤独时，我才心想，嗯，也许那些对话是他与任何人仅有的几次交流之一。最终，拉杰什找到了一份工作和一个家。然而，当维韦克上高中时，拉杰什失业了。这是一个沉重的打击。当时他正往印度寄钱
He would tell me about the concrete that was being poured, about the trusses that were being put up, about the different types of construction that could be used to build a house. And it was only years later when I realized just how lonely Rajesh was that I thought, hmm, perhaps those conversations were one of the few that he was having with anyone. Eventually, Rajesh found a job and a home. When Vivek was in high school, however, Rajesh lost his job. It was a terrible blow. It came at a time when he was sending money back to India
来支付他女儿的婚礼费用。这伤了他的自尊，他不想告诉印度的人、那里的家人他失业了。所以他对他们保密了。事实上，有很长一段时间他甚至没有告诉我们。但他继续努力寻找工作。
to pay for his daughter's wedding. It hurt his pride, and he didn't want to tell people in India, the family back there, that he had lost his job. So he kept it a secret from them. He didn't even tell us, actually, for a significant amount of time. But he continued to try to look for jobs.
我父亲得知后，也试图帮他寻找额外的工作。但运气并不好，拉杰什不仅害羞，而且他的英语也不是那么容易让人听懂。这使得人们很难与他沟通。从求职面试的角度来看，这是一个相当难以跨越的障碍。随着时间的推移，拉杰什开始认为这个障碍是不可逾越的。警告：接下来的部分内容将涉及自杀讨论。
My father, when he found out, tried to help him find additional jobs as well. But without much luck, Rajesh was not only shy, but his English was not so easy to understand. And that made it challenging for people to communicate with him. And from a job interview perspective, it was quite a barrier to a surmount. In time, Rajesh came to see that barrier as insurmountable. A warning that this next part of the story involves a discussion of suicide.
有一天，我正在家里和姐姐一起工作。我们在餐桌旁做家庭作业。当时我正在读高中。电话响了。我父母不在家，那个星期天他们去寺庙了。我接了电话，那是索菲亚打来的，她是我的叔叔拉杰什的室友。
What happened one day is I was working at home on a Sunday with my sister. We were doing homework at the dining table. I was in high school at the time. And the phone rang. My parents were not home They had gone to the temple on that particular Sunday And I picked up the phone and it was Sophia who was My uncle Rajesh's roommate and
索菲亚说：我们在敲门，但他没有开门。当时我想，他肯定是因为耳背所以没听到，因为他耳聋得非常厉害。当他的助听器摘下来时，你知道的，哪怕你在旁边引爆一颗炸弹他都听不见。他的听力简直差得难以置信。所以我非常确定就是这么回事。于是我说：使劲砸门吧。如果需要的话，去外面砸窗户。我确信他在里面。于是她照做了。几分钟后她回来，说他还是没有应答。这时我开始担心了。我说，好吧，如果他不应答，
Sophia said we're knocking on the door, but he's not opening the door now I figured he must just not have heard her because he was extremely hard of hearing. And when his hearing aids were out, you could, you know, you could set off a bomb and he wouldn't hear it. He was just incredibly hard of hearing. And so I was pretty sure that's what it was. So I said, just bang really hard on the door. And if you need to, just go outside and bang on the window. I'm sure he's in there. So she did that. And she came back a few minutes later and said he's still not answering. Then I started to get worried. So I said, well, if he's not answering,
也许你应该报警，让他们来破门而入。她说，我这就去。然后她挂断了电话。接下来的几分钟，大概五到十分钟，感觉像几个小时一样漫长，我非常担心。我不知道发生了什么。我和姐姐只是紧紧缩在电话旁，直到电话终于响了。我们接起来，是索菲亚。她说，我们破门而入，找到了他。他死了。他悬挂在天花板上。
maybe you should call the police and have them come and break down the door. And she said, let me do that. And she hung up. And those next few minutes, which were maybe five or ten minutes, felt like hours, I was so worried. I didn't know what was going on. And my sister and I were just huddled by the phone until they finally rang. And then we picked it up, and it was Sophia. She said, we broke down the door, and we found him. He's dead. He's hanging from the ceiling.
那一刻，感觉就像有人重重地给了我一拳。我从未经历过家族中或亲密朋友中有人自杀。我根本不知道这种事对拉杰什来说也是可能的，他当时的内心一定感到无比孤独和悲伤。我在那里瘫坐了几分钟。不知道该说什么，也不知道该做什么。我们花了几个月甚至几年时间来努力理解那个
And that moment, it was like somebody had punched me in the gut. I had never experienced suicide in the family or among a close friend. I had no idea that this was even a possibility for Rajesh, that he was feeling as lonely and as sad as he must have been feeling. I was just paralyzed for a few minutes there. Not sure what to say and not sure what to do. We struggled for months, if not years, to make sense of that
时刻以及发生的事情。直到后来我才逐渐意识到，拉杰什一直在与悲伤的深渊作斗争。那比我们许多人想象的要深得多。因此我们感到非常内疚，心想：我们是不是漏掉了什么迹象？我们本该给予他更多支持吗？每当我回想起小时候在家里绕着建筑工地散步并与他交谈的日子，我就会意识到，也许那些对话比我想象的更有意义。我很感激自己曾有机会与他进行那些交流，
moment of what had happened. It was only with time that I came to realize that Radji had been struggling with the well of sadness. It was far deeper than many of us probably imagined. So we felt a lot of guilt wondering, did we miss a sign? Should we have been more supportive of him? I think back on those days as a child when I would walk around the construction side at home and have those conversations with him, and I now realize that perhaps those conversations meant more than I had thought. I feel grateful that I had the opportunity to have those exchanges with them,
因为那是为数不多的几个时刻，我看到他的脸上洋溢着喜悦，并在他的声音中听到这种喜悦，当他谈到他热爱的事物——建筑和施工时。我想花点时间谈谈社交孤立、孤独与自杀现象之间的普遍联系。这些数字确实惊人，维韦克。美国每年有45,000人自杀，而在世界范围内，
because those are the few moments where I saw joy on his face and heard it in his voice as he talked about what he loved, which was architecture and construction. I wanna talk for a moment about the general connection between social isolation and loneliness and the phenomenon of suicide. The numbers are really staggering, Vivek. 45,000 people commit suicide in the United States every year worldwide.
大约有80万人。我们没有对这个问题给予更多的关注，这确实令人惊讶，不仅在美国，在全世界也是如此。确实如此。遗憾的是，尽管自杀率在世界上某些国家有所改善，但在包括美国在内的其他国家却一直在恶化。我认为部分原因在于，我们没有把自杀作为一个如此深远的问题来进行讨论或处理，其原因有很多。
It's about 800,000 people. It's really astonishing that we don't pay more attention to the problem, not just in the United States, but around the world. Well, it is. And suicide, sadly, although it's been improving in some countries around the world, has been worsening in others, including the United States. And I think part, there's so many reasons why I think we don't talk about or deal with suicide as profound an issue as it is.
首先，我认为这让人感到不舒服。其次，我认为这也让人感到无助。严重抑郁症和自杀的根源很复杂。要理解它们的来源并不总是那么容易。人们对自杀也有很多复杂的感受，无论这些感受是根植于宗教信仰还是文化规范。但最根本的是，当谈到自杀、谈到抑郁症时，我们拥有的最大资源之一，
I think it makes people uncomfortable, number one. And I think it also makes people feel helpless. The roots of deep depression and suicide are complicated. And it's not always easy to understand where they come from. There are also lots of mixed feelings that people have about suicide, whether those are rooted in religious belief or on cultural norms. But the bottom line is, when it comes to suicide, when it comes to depression, that one of the greatest resources we have,
我们口袋里拥有的最具治愈力的力量之一，就是我们与他人的关系。在我们需要的时候，这些关系可能并不总是触手可及，但作为一名多年来开过许多处方的医生，我脱口而出的是，我们拥有的最强大的药物之一就是爱，而传递这种爱的载体就是人际关系。在一个我们正与如此高的自杀率抗争的时代，在一个我们看到抑郁和焦虑达到如此高水平的时代，尤其是在年轻人当中，我认为比以往任何时候都更重要的是，我们要重新思考并利用人际关系的力量，认识到它们不仅仅是锦上添花，而是必不可少的。它们是我们变得健康、康复和强壮的重要基石。
one of the most powerful sources of healing that we have in our back pocket, our relationships with others, those relationships may not always feel available in the moments that we want them, but it stands out to me, despite being a doctor who has prescribed a number of medications over the years, that one of the most powerful medicines we have is love, and the vehicle through which that love is delivered are relationships. And at a time when we are struggling with such high levels of suicide, at a time when we're seeing such high levels of depression and anxiety, particularly among young people, I think it's more important than ever that we rethink and harness the power of relationships and recognize that they are not just nice to have, but they are necessary to have. They are an essential part of the foundation that makes us healthy, well and strong.
我想知道，作为一名医生和前外科医生总长，你如何看待这些问题在冠状病毒大流行背景下的演变。我们都被告知要实行社交距离。我们很少见朋友，和家人紧密呆在一起，或者我们许多人独自宅在家里。你认为这场大流行会加剧全球的社交孤立吗？我认为确实存在这种真正的可能性：为了压平这波COVID-19感染曲线而要求我们保持的物理距离，很可能会导致更多的孤独感。我认为这可能会导致一场“社交衰退”（如果可以这样称呼的话），其特征是随着我们隔离的时间越来越长，孤独感不断加深。但我认为并非一定如此。事实上，我认为这有可能是一个契机，让我们重新思考并以人际关系为中心重塑我们的生活，
I'm wondering how, as a doctor and as former Surgeon General, you see these issues playing out in the context of the coronavirus pandemic. We're all being told to practice social distancing. We are meeting few friends, we are hunkered down with family, or many of us hunkered down by ourselves. Can you see this pandemic increasing social isolation worldwide? I think there's a real possibility that the physical distancing we're being asked to observe to tamp down this wave of COVID-19 infection could very well contribute to more loneliness. I think it could contribute to a social recession, if you will, marked by deepening levels of loneliness as we stay apart for longer and longer periods of time. But I don't think it has to be that way. In fact, I think this is potentially an opportunity for us to rethink and recenter our lives around relationships,
重新认识并可能更深刻地体会到人际关系在我们生活中的角色和力量，不仅是对我们的配偶、家人和密友，还包括我们与工作中的同事、学校里的同学，甚至与社区中陌生人所共享的关系。让我震惊的是，在这样一个我们都被要求隔离的时刻，当我绕着我居住的街区散步时，如果我看到有人朝相反方向走来，他们会热情地挥手并微笑，仿佛他们是如此渴望人类的接触。
to recognize once again, and perhaps even more deeply appreciate the role and power that relationships have in our lives, not just to our spouses and our family members and our close friends, but also the relationships we share with colleagues at work, with classmates at school, and even with strangers in our community. And I'm struck that in a moment like this when we're all being asked to separate, that when I go for a walk around the circle and which I live, and if I see somebody walking in the opposite direction, they wave furiously and smile as if they're just so hungry for human contact.
你知道吗，我也会同样热情地挥手并微笑，因为我也渴望人类的接触。我对生命中的陌生人、对那些我不认识的面孔，以及对我现在看到其实相当有价值的人际关系，有了一种全新的感激之情。因此我认为，如果我们带着有意识的意图来对待这个时刻，如果我们带着这样一种心态来对待这段时间——即我们要加倍努力，既关注与其他人相处的时间质量，也关注我们投入在所爱之人身上的时间数量——那么我想，我们也许能够以比开始时更强大的人类连接力量走出困境。我们或许可以利用COVID-19作为重塑我们对待人际关系方式的一种途径，并重新审视人际关系在我们生活优先级列表中的地位。稍后回来，我们将探讨孤独往往如何滋生孤独，以及我们如何开始打破这个循环。这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。今天我与医生维韦克·穆尔蒂（美国前外科医生总长）进行对话。维韦克，研究人员提出了许多理论来解释孤独。其中最激进的一个理论与我们的进化史有关。
And you know what, I wave back just as enthusiastically and smile as if they're just so hungry for human contact. And you know what, I wave back just as enthusiastically because I too am hungry for human contact. I feel a renewed appreciation for the strangers in my life, for the faces that I don't recognize, but for the relationships that I now see are actually quite valuable. So I think that if we approach this moment with intentionality, if we approach this time with a mindset that we are going to double down and focus on both the quality of our time with other people as well as the quantity of time that we dedicate to the people we love, then I think that we may be able to come out of this much stronger in terms of our human
这个理论对为什么感到孤独会如此痛苦是怎么说的？嗯，关于孤独的进化理论告诉我们，我们生来就是社交动物，依靠彼此来获得生存优势。几千年前，当我们是苔原上的猎人时，聚在一起、对人际关系感兴趣，增加了我们汇集食物并在每天都能获得一些食物而不是挨饿的机会。这使得我们更有可能保护自己免受掠食者的侵害，因为我们可以轮流在夜间放哨，例如。它还帮助我们做一些事情，比如分担育儿责任，照看别人的孩子，以便他们可以出去打猎或采集水果和蔬菜。当我们彼此分离时，那会让我们处于一种危险状态。当我们彼此分离时，那会让人处于一种危险状态，而这种危险会以应激状态的形式在我们的身体中产生共鸣，其特征是应激激素的大量涌出，
connections with each other than when we began, we may be able to use COVID-19 as a way to reset how we approach relationships and to revisit the place that relationships have in our live priority list. When we come back, while loneliness often begets loneliness and how we can begin to break the cycle. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. I'm speaking today with physician Vivek Murthy, the former surgeon general of the United States. Vivek researchers have offered many theories to understand loneliness. One of the most provocative has to do with our evolutionary history.
这在短期内可能是有益的，因为它们可以集中你的注意力，并确保如果掠食者确实在你身后时，你能迅速作出反应。但从长远来看，这种应激状态可能是有害的。当你把自己带回现代时，你会发现，尽管我们的环境与猎人采集的时代相比发生了巨大变化，但我们的身体并没有太大不同，神经系统对与人分离的反应方式、我们对感到孤独的反应方式，在经历方面惊人地相似。
What does this theory say about why being lonely hurts so much? Well, the evolutionary theory around loneliness tells us that we were designed to be social creatures that relied on each other for a survival advantage. Thousands of years ago when we were hunter-gatherers on the Tundra, being together interested in relationships, increased the chances that we could pull our food and all have some food day- day as opposed to starving. It made it more likely that we could protect ourselves from predators because we could take turns taking watch at night, for example. It also helped us do things like share responsibility for childcare and watch over other people's kids so that they could go out and hunt or gather fruit and vegetables. When we were separated from each other, that place is in a state of danger. When we were separated from each other, that place us in a state of danger, and that danger resonated through our body in the form of a stress state that was marked by an outflow of stress hormones,
一种升高的应激状态。再次强调，在短期内，这可能是有益的。事实上，我们可以将孤独视为一种自然的信号，就像饥饿或口渴一样，当我们缺少生存所需的东西时就会出现，在这种情况下，就是社会连接。如果我们利用这个信号去寻找有意义的人类连接，孤独感可能会消退；但如果这种感觉持续很长时间，
which in the short term could be beneficial, because they could focus your mind and ensure that you could react quickly if a predator was indeed behind you. But in the long term, that stress state can be harmful. When you transport yourself back to the modern day, what you find is that even though our circumstances have changed dramatically from those hunter-gatherer days, that our bodies are not so different and the way our nervous system reacts to being separated from people, the way we react to feeling lonely is remarkably similar in terms of experiencing
如果它变成慢性的，随之而来的压力最终会导致我们体内的炎症水平升高，并增加我们患心脏病等慢性疾病的风险。孤独的奇异后果之一不仅是你感觉痛苦，对于心脏病等慢性疾病也是如此。孤独的一个奇怪后果不仅是你感到痛苦，而且你会对感觉像是自己社交无能的耻辱感感到羞愧。我想问问你自己的经历，维韦克。当你还是个孩子的时候，父母把你送到学校时，你每天胃里都有一只宠物。为什么会这样？嗯，小学对我和是一段艰难的时期。
an elevated stress state. And again, in the short term, this can be beneficial. We can think of loneliness, in fact, as a natural signal, like hunger or thirst, that come about when we're missing something that we need for survival, in this case, social connection. And if we use that signal to then seek out meaningful human connection, the feeling of loneliness may subside, but if that feeling persists for a long period of time,
那是充满巨大孤独感的时期。你知道，作为一个孩子，我在家里感觉好极了。我有两个非常爱我的父母，我心里很清楚。我有一个非常爱我、照顾我的姐姐。我在家里感觉棒极了，但学校完全是另一回事，因为作为一个极其害羞的孩子，我很难发起对话
if it becomes chronic, the stress that comes with it can ultimately lead to higher levels of inflammation in our body and increase our risk for chronic illnesses like heart disease. One of the peculiar consequences of loneliness is not just that you feel miserable, for chronic illness is like heart disease. One of the peculiar consequences of loneliness is not just that you feel miserable, but that you feel shame at what feels like your own social ineptitude. I want to ask you about your own experience here, Vivek. When you were a kid, you got a pet in your stomach every day when your parents dropped you off at school. Why was that? Well, elementary school was a difficult time for me.
与别的孩子交往并接近他们。我想花时间建立友谊，但这些真的很难得到。因此，学校里的每一天其实都是一次孤独的经历。对我来说，一天中最可怕的部分也许是午餐时间，当我走进食堂时，担心自己会找不到人坐在旁边，或者桌子旁没有空凳子了。
It was a time of great loneliness. You know, as a child, I felt amazing at home. I had two parents who loved me dearly and I knew it. I had a sister who loved me very much and took care of me. I felt wonderful at home, but school was an entirely different matter because as an extremely shy child, I had a hard time starting conversations
这种情况持续了好几年。我仍然记得在那几年里，我只是在等待三点钟的钟声敲响，这样我就可以冲到学校前面，看到母亲在她的车里等候，然后跳上车，回到家里的安全和保障中。所以，直到今天，这仍然是一个深深烙印在我心里的记忆。尽管我现在没有在学校里那种深深的孤独感了。
with other kids and approaching them. And I wanted to spend time and build friendships, but they were just hard to come by. And so each day at school was in fact a lonely experience. And perhaps the most scary part of the day for me was lunchtime when I would walk into the cafeteria, worried that I would have no one to sit next to or that there would be no empty stools available
它提醒我，孤独可以有多么痛苦，有多少人在默默忍受着孤独的痛苦，无论是孩子还是成年人。你说你和父母非常亲近，父母爱你，你也信任他们。你有没有向他们吐露心声，告诉他们在学校感到孤独？你知道，我从来没有告诉过父母，因为我感到羞愧。我担心如果我说自己感到孤独
by the tables. So that was true for a number of years. I still remember during those years that I would just be waiting for the bell to ring at three o'clock so that I could rush back to the front of the school and find my mother waiting in her car and jump in and be taken back to the safety and security of home. So that remains, you know, even to this day as a very deeply seared memory. And even though I don't feel the same deep loneliness that I did back then in school.
在学校里交朋友有困难，这会显得我在某种程度上社交上有缺陷，或者我不知怎么的不讨人喜欢，我感到很尴尬。我不想和他们进行那样的对话。向自己承认这一点已经够难的了。所以这里面有一个深刻的讽刺，维韦克，它超出了你的个人故事，那就是孤独的人往往很难主动联系并向其他人寻求帮助。
It reminds me of how painful loneliness can be and of how many people suffer in silence with feelings of loneliness, whether they're a child or an adult. You say that you were very close to your parents and your parents loved you and you trusted them. Did you ever confide in them and tell them that you were lonely at school? You know, I never did tell my parents because I was ashamed. I worried that if I said that I was feeling lonely
而那些乐意帮忙、甚至渴望帮忙的人，却不知道该如何联系，或者甚至不知道有问题存在。所以这里面有一种真正的悲伤，那就是你遇到了一个严重的问题：光谱两端的人都渴望解决方案，然而事情却没有发生。完全正确。这也是孤独的谜团之一，是一个悖论，它导致人们在孤独的深渊中越陷越深，因为他们因为孤独而进一步退缩，陷入羞耻之中，最终离他们所需要的人类连接越来越远。
at school and having a hard time making friends, that it would seem like I was socially deficient in some way or that I somehow wasn't likeable and I was embarrassed. I didn't want to have that conversation with them. And it was hard enough to admit it to myself. So there's a deep irony here, Vivek, and it goes beyond your personal story, which is that lonely people often have a really difficult time reaching out and asking other people for help.
讽刺的是，我认为还有一件事，那就是如果我们对生活中的其他人敞开心扉，坦白我们所经历的事情，我们往往可以从他们那里获得更多的帮助、更多的同情和支持。但对孤独的羞耻感使得这很难做到。除了羞耻感之外，还有另一件事正在发生，那就是在更深层的生物学层面上，因为孤独是一种威胁状态和应激状态，我们发现有几种现象
And other people who would be glad to help, and in fact want to help, don't know how to reach out, or don't even know that there's a problem. And so there's a real sort of sadness here, which is that you have a profound problem where you have people eager for a solution at both ends of the spectrum, and yet it doesn't happen. That's exactly right. And this is one of the conundrums of loneliness, one of the paradoxes which leads people to spiral deeper and deeper into a well of loneliness as they withdraw further and further in shame because they're lonely and end up moving farther away from the
在这里发生，最终会适得其反。其一是，随着我们的威胁水平上升，我们往往会以比平时更大的怀疑态度来看待周围的人，甚至是周围的关怀行为。当我们长期感到孤独时，我们也倾向于将注意力更多地转向自己，而远离其他人。从进化的角度来看这说得通，因为当你处于威胁状态时，你会想关注自己以确保自己安全。但这也会使得你在与其他人的互动中更难建立牢固的连接。
human connections that they need. The irony is I think that also that there's often more help out there, more compassion and support that we may be able to get from others in our lives if we were open with them about what we were experiencing. But the shame around loneliness makes it hard to do that. There's something else that's going on in addition to the shame, which is that at a deeper biological level, because loneliness is a state of threat and a state of stress, we find that there are a couple of phenomena
但也许最阴险的是，当我们与长期的孤独抗争时，它会侵蚀我们的自尊，我们开始相信，我们之所以孤独是因为我们不讨人喜欢或不可爱。因此，通过这些方式，孤独自我滋长，这就是为什么从局外人的角度来看，人们可能会想：如果你感到孤独，为什么不直接去认识人呢？为什么不去参加派对呢？为什么不联系朋友并告诉他们你想建立连接呢？好吧，这看起来是理性的做法，但当你了解孤独的机制
in the take place here that end up being counterproductive. One is that as our threat level rises, we tend to perceive people and even acts of outreach around us with greater suspicion than we otherwise might do. We also tend to shift our focus when we're chronically lonely more toward ourselves and away from other people. And that makes sense from an evolutionary standpoint because when you're in a threat state, you want to focus on yourself to make sure that you're safe. But that can also make it harder when you're interacting with other people to form a strong connection.
以及与孤独相关的羞耻感时，你很快就会发现，要打破这种恶性循环并不是那么容易。在与全国各地人们的对话中，维韦克，你得出的结论是，往往孤独并不总是表现为孤独，它会表现为其他事情。它以许多其他方式表现出来，对我们的行为和健康产生深远的影响。比如什么？你指的是什么？我同许多老年男性的家属交谈过，这些男性最近刚刚退休或经历了疾病，对那些最近刚退休或经历疾病的老年男性来说，很明显他们正在应付相当程度的孤独，但这表现为愤怒和易怒。
But perhaps most insidious of all, when we struggle with chronic loneliness, it chips away at our self-esteem, and we start to believe that the reason that we're lonely is because we're not likable or not lovable. And so in these ways, loneliness builds on itself, and that's why looking at it from the outside, one might wonder, well, if you're lonely, why don't you just go meet people? Why don't you just go to a party? Why don't you just reach out to friends and tell them that you want to connect? Well it seems like they're rational thing to do, but when you understand the mechanisms
对有些人来说，孤独表现为抑郁情绪；对另一些人来说，表现为焦虑，因为他们越来越担心自己为什么没有与其他人建立连接。因此，我们可能会离开并心想：这个人有焦虑症，那个人有抑郁症，或者这个人有愤怒问题或情绪障碍。在某些情况下，这确实可能是事实，但通常情况可能是孤独以这些不同方式表现出来。我也意识到，我们在报纸上读到许多一线问题——那些我在担任外科医生总长期间花了很多时间处理的问题，包括阿片类药物流行病、更广泛的瘾癖以及暴力问题——这些同样是由孤独助长的。孤独可能不是所有这些挑战的全部原因，但孤独确实促成了
of loneliness and the shame associated with loneliness, it quickly becomes apparent that that downward spiral is not so easy to break. In your conversations with people around the country with Aik, you came to the conclusion that very often loneliness does not always manifest itself as loneliness, that it manifests as other things. It shows up in lots of other ways that actually have profound effects on our behavior and our health. Like what? What did you have in mind? I spoke to many family members of older men who had recently retired or experienced illness, of older men who had recently retired or experienced illness, and who it became clear that they were dealing with a decent amount of loneliness, but that was manifest as anger and irritability.
瘾癖和暴力的增加，而且它往往也是这些状况的结果。说来有趣，如果你看看《匿名戒酒会》创始人的著作，他说的有趣的事情之一就是孤独是酗酒的根源之一。他说，正如他所说的那样，孤独是酒鬼的伴侣。他说，当我们思考如何应对酒精成瘾的挑战时，我们必须考虑如何在人们的生活中建立社群和连接，因为这是治愈过程中同等重要的一部分，就像他们可能得到的传统医疗护理一样。
With some people loneliness shows up as a depressed mood, with others it shows up as anxiety, as they worry more and more about why it is that they're not connected with other people. And so we may walk away thinking, you know, this person struggles with anxiety or that one with depression or this person has anger issues or mood disorder. And in some cases that very well may be the fact, but it can often be the case that it is loneliness manifesting like in these different ways. What I also realized is that many of the frontline issues that we read about in the paper today, issues that I worked on quite a bit during my time as surgeon general, including the opioid epidemic and addiction more broadly and the issue of violence, that these are also fed by loneliness. Loneliness may not be the entire cause of all these challenges, but loneliness contributes
当你成为一名医生时，你很早就遇到了一位病人。他叫詹姆斯，他告诉你，他中彩票的那天是他一生中最糟糕的一天。他是什么意思？你从他的故事中获得了什么，维韦克？这是多年来我与病人进行的较为引人注目的对话之一，它发生在我职业生涯的早期，当时我在初级保健诊所，詹姆斯走了进来。
to the rise of addiction and violence, and it often is a consequence as well of these conditions. If you interestingly enough, if you look at the writings of the founder of Alcoholics Anonymous, one of the interesting things that he says is that loneliness is one of the origins of alcoholism. He says that loneliness is the companion, if you will, of the alcoholics he put it. And he says that as we think about how to address our challenges with alcohol addiction, we have to think about how we build community and connection into people's lives because that is an equally important part of the healing process as is the
我第一次见到他，我查看了他的病历，发现他患有糖尿病和高血压，还在与肥胖作斗争。他对我说的第一句话之一就是他中了彩票，这是他经历过的最糟糕的事情之一。我的脸一定露出了惊讶的表情，因为他说：噢，你想让我解释一下为什么吗？我说：我很乐意听听，我从来没见过中彩票的人，也没想到这会是史上最糟糕的事。他说的是，在他中彩票之前，你知道的，
traditional medical care that they may receive. When you became a doctor, you met a patient early on. His name was James, and he told you that the day he won the lottery was the worst day of his life. What did he mean by that? And what have you taken from his story, Vivek? This was one of the more striking conversations I had with patients over the years, and it happened very early on in my career when I was in primary care clinic and James walked in
他们可能接受的传统医疗护理。当你成为一名医生时，你很早就遇到了一位病人。他的名字叫詹姆斯，他告诉你他中彩票的那天是他一生中最糟糕的一天。他是那个意思吗？维韦克，你从他的故事中领悟到了什么？这是我多年来与患者进行的最引人注目的对话之一，它发生在我职业生涯的早期，当时我在初级保健诊所，詹姆斯走了进来
I was meeting him for the first time I had reviewed his chart and found out that he had diabetes and high blood pressure It was struggling with obesity as well And one of the first things that he said to me was that he won the lottery and it was one of the worst things that ever happened to him and The surprise must have shown in my face because he said, oh, you want me to explain why? And I said, I would love for you to have one never met somebody who won the lottery, but also didn't expect that it would be the worst thing ever. What he said is that before he won the lottery, you know,
我是第一次见到他。我查看了他的病历，发现他患有糖尿病和高血压，还在与肥胖作斗争。他对我说的第一件事就是他中了彩票，这是他经历过的最糟糕的事情之一。我的脸一定露出了惊讶的表情，因为他说：“哦，你想让我解释一下为什么吗？”我说：“我很想听听，我从来没见过中彩票的人，也没想到这会是有史以来最糟糕的事情。”他说的是，在他中彩票之前，你知道的
he used to work at a bakery and he had colleagues in the bakery that he loved. He had customers who loved what he made. He didn't make a lot of money and so he lived in a modest neighborhood in the Boston area. But he knew his neighbors and he liked them. So he had a modest life as he described it. But after he won the lottery, he figured, gosh, I've got everything that I need. I don't need to work anymore. So he quit his job. He sold his house and he moved to an expensive neighborhood on the water, a negated community where everyone had big houses and large properties and big fences
他过去在一家面包店工作，店里有他深爱的同事。他的顾客也喜欢他做点心。他赚的钱不多，所以住在波士顿地区的一个普通街区里。但他认识邻居们，也很喜欢他们。正如他所描述的，他过着简朴的生活。但在赢得彩票后，他心想，天哪，我需要的一切都有了。我再也不用工作了。于是他辞了职。他卖掉了房子，搬到了水边一个昂贵的社区，那是一个门禁社区，每个人都有大房子、大地产和高高的栅栏
in between their properties. And he started to realize that having, quote unquote, made it, And he started to realize that having quote-unquote made it, he now felt quite lonely. He didn't have those relationships that he realized had been so important to him, far more important than he had thought with his customers and colleagues and neighbors. And as he became lonelier, he became angrier as well. He found himself angry at his neighbors because they had big fences and didn't seem to care about him or anyone else. He found himself angry at old friends from the bakery who he felt weren't keeping in touch with him. He became angry and he was alone and was shortly after that that he developed obesity and diabetes and high blood pressure and that's what brought him in to see me. And it was a powerful reminder
在他们的房产之间。他开始意识到，在所谓的“成功”之后，他现在感到相当孤独。他没有那些他意识到对自己如此重要的关系，远比他原以为的与顾客、同事和邻居的关系更重要。随着他越来越孤独，他也变得越来越愤怒。他发现自己对邻居感到生气，因为他们有高高的栅栏，似乎并不关心他或其他任何人。他发现自己对面包店的老朋友感到生气，他觉得他们没有和自己保持联系。他变得愤怒，而且孤单，也就是在那之后不久，他患上了肥胖症、糖尿病和高血压，而这正是他来看病的原因。这是一个强有力的提醒
for me of two things. One, it was a humbling reminder that all of the things that I had studied in medical school had not really prepared me for this moment because I had never really studied anything about loneliness or understood it to be a problem. I'll tell you, Shankar, that was a hard moment for me also because I felt helpless. I didn't know what to offer him. I felt utterly ill-equipped to address what was clearly the issue that was on his mind. I could tinker with his by-pressure medicines, I could adjust his insulin, and I did do those things.
对我来说，主要有两点。第一，这是一个谦卑的提醒，我在医学院学到的一切其实都没有为这一刻做好准备，因为我从未真正研究过任何关于孤独的内容，也没有把它理解为一个问题。我告诉你，山卡尔，那对我来说也是艰难的一刻，因为我感到无助。我不知道能为他提供什么。对于如何解决显然盘旋在他脑海中的问题，我感到彻底的无能为力。我可以调整他的降压药，我可以调整他的胰岛素，我也确实做了这些。
But I left with this feeling of dissatisfaction, knowing that I was not equipped in that moment to provide him what he needed. When we come back, how to decrease loneliness and increase social connection? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is NPR. Former Surgeon General Vivek Murthy believes that social isolation and loneliness are major public health problems in the United States. We've looked at the scope of the problem and the science of loneliness.
但我离开时带着一种不满的感觉，我知道在那一刻我没有能力为他提供他所需要的东西。稍后回来，如何减少孤独感并增加社会联系？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是山卡尔·维达antam。这里是美国国家公共电台。前美国外科医生总长维韦克·穆尔蒂认为，社会隔离和孤独是美国重大的公共卫生问题。我们已经探讨了问题的范围和孤独的科学。
Now we turn to solutions. Vivek, I'm wondering if you can tell me the story of a young woman, Serena, when she first got to college at the University of Pennsylvania, she was terribly lonely and like you in elementary school she felt like she was the only one with the problem. But when she got back home over the summer after her first year at school, she did a few things that really helped her. What did she do? Well, Serena, after her very lonely first year in college, came home and she re-engaged in some of the activities that had given her joy. She loved beekeeping and so she started taking care of bees again.
现在我们转向解决方案。维韦克，我想知道你是否能给我讲讲一个年轻女孩塞琳娜的故事，当她刚进入宾夕法尼亚大学上大学时，她感到非常孤独，就像你上小学时一样，她觉得自己是唯一有这个问题的人。但当她在学校的第一年后暑假回家时，她做了一些真正帮助到她的事情。她做了什么？嗯，塞琳娜在经历了极其孤独的大学第一年后，回到家里，重新参与了一些曾带给她快乐的活动。她热爱养蜂，于是她开始重新照顾蜜蜂。
She joined a yoga group and not only enjoyed the physical practice of yoga and the relaxation that brought her, but she bonded with the other people who had come together to take classes that summer. She also spent time with her parents and with good friends from high school that she had come to know over the years and who knew her authentically for who she was. And those experiences together were a reminder to her of who she could be and who she actually really was when she was joyful and happy and connected. That summer was like taking a cloth and wiping down this mirror that had become so frosted that she had lost sight of who she was
她加入了一个瑜伽小组，不仅享受瑜伽的身体练习和它带来的放松，还与那个夏天聚在一起上课其他人建立了深厚的联系。她还花时间陪父母和高中时的好朋友，这些朋友是她多年来认识的，并且真正懂她本来的样子。这些共同的经历提醒着她，当她快乐、幸福和与他人连接时，她可以是谁，她实际上真正是谁。那个夏天就像是用一块布擦拭一面沾满冰花的镜子，这面镜子已经模糊得让她迷失了自我
and now she could finally see the joyful, happy person, that she and her family had always known her to be. So you see that one of the things that Serena learned to do was to connect with herself. You just talked about some of the ways in which she learned to do that. Why is connecting with yourself important to being able to connect with others? Connection to self, it turns out, is the foundation that we need to connect to other people. When we're connected to ourselves, we understand that we have self-worth. We understand that we have value to bring to the world.
而现在她终于能看到那个快乐、幸福的人，她和家人一直都知道的那个人。所以你看，塞琳娜学会做的事情之一就是与自己连接。你刚才谈到了她学会做到这一点的某些方式。为什么与自己连接对于能够与他人连接如此重要？事实证明，与自我的连接是我们连接其他人所需的基础。当我们与自己连接时，我们明白自己具有自我价值。我们明白我们有价值带给世界。
And the truth is that many of us walk around, not necessarily believing that or having moments of doubt, but we're not sure that we're if we're good enough. It's not surprising that that's the case, because so much around us emphasizes that we aren't enough, that we're not thin enough, or good looking enough, or rich enough, or funny enough, or famous enough. But the truth is that that erosion of confidence in ourselves, of comfort with who we are,
而事实是，我们许多人走来走去，并不一定完全相信这一点，或者会有怀疑的时刻，但我们不确定自己是否足够好。这并不令人意外，因为我们周围有太多事物强调我们还不够好，我们不够苗条，或者不够好看，或者不够富有，或者不够有趣，或者不够出名。但事实是，这种对自我自信的侵蚀，对我们本然样子的不适，
that can impair our ability to reach out to and connect to other people. In Serena's case, one of the things that she had to do was to re-encore herself and get comfortable with who she was at a time where her world was turned upside down after she went to college. And it turns out that there are really two components to connection to self. Two components, if you will, to self acceptance. And those are self-knowledge and self-compassion. For Serena, it was the chance to recapture solitude in a place of comfort that allowed her to reflect more deeply on her experiences.
这会削弱我们向外伸出援手并与他人连接的能力。对塞琳娜来说，她不得不做的事情之一就是重新锚定自己，并在她上大学后世界天翻地覆的时刻，对自己的身份感到舒适。事实证明，与自我的连接实际上有两个组成部分。如果你愿意的话，自我接纳有两个组成部分。那就是自我认知和自我同情。对塞琳娜来说，这是一个在舒适的地方重新夺回独处机会的机会，这让她能够更深入地反思自己的经历。
It was a chance to talk to people about her experiences who knew her and trusted her, that helped her start to see that the tendencies she had to want to have more time to herself, for example, these were not the signs of somebody who was socially deficient. These are the signs of somebody who tended to be introverted by nature, and that was just who she was. So as she gained knowledge of who she was and what she needed, she also realized that she needed to be compassionate and forgiving toward herself, that it wasn't enough to know what she needed and what her traits were, but she had to be able to accept herself for who she was.
这是一个与了解她、信任她的人谈论她经历的机会，这帮助她开始认识到，她想要更多独处时间的倾向，例如，这些并不是社交能力不足的人的迹象。这些是一个天生内向的人的迹象，这正是她本来的样子。因此，随着她对自己是谁以及自己需要什么的了解加深，她也意识到她需要对自己保持同情和宽容，仅仅知道自己需要什么和自己的特质是不够的，她必须能够接受本来的自己。
I'm wondering during a time like we're going through right now, where many of us are quarantining ourselves because of the coronavirus pandemic. Do you think that these practices involving sort of deliberate solitude could be a tool to learn something about ourselves and learn how to stave off loneliness? I do think solitude is really important right now. You know, it's powerful about solitude is it gives us both the time to quieten the noise around us, but it also gives us the opportunity to reflect and to simply be. You know, there's attention in our modern world between being and doing. We're built as
我想知道，在我们目前经历的这段时期里，由于冠状病毒大流行，我们中的许多人都在自我隔离。你认为这些涉及某种刻意独处的练习，能成为了解我们自己并学会击退孤独的工具吗？我确实认为独处现在非常重要。你知道，独处的力量在于它既给了我们时间来平息身边的噪音，也给了我们反思和单纯存在的机会。你知道，在我们的现代世界中，存在着存在（being）与行动（doing）之间的张力。我们的文化
a culture around action. If there's a problem, the way we address it is through action. What do we do? What do we call? What action do we take? What plan do we execute? It's all about action. But one of the things that I have come to understand more deeply in the process of talking to people and researching this topic of loneliness
是围绕行动构建的。如果出现问题，我们解决它的方式就是通过行动。我们做什么？我们给谁打电话？我们采取什么行动？我们执行什么计划？这全都是关于行动的。但我通过与人们交谈和研究孤独这个话题的过程中更深地理解的一件事是
is it being proceeds action? And we all know this in our own lives. We know that when we spend time getting into the right frame of mind, then often we can be much more effective in the action that we take. And so solitude is extraordinarily powerful because it allows us to focus again on being and solitude can be experienced in different ways. Simply spending five minutes sitting outside and feeling the wind against your face, or spending time just listening to the birds chirping or to the conversation around you or to the ambient noise and just
存在先于行动。我们每个人在自己的生活中都知道这一点。我们知道，当我们花时间进入正确的精神状态时，我们通常能够更有效地采取行动。因此，独处是异常强大的，因为它使我们能够重新专注于存在，并且可以通过不同的方式体验独处。仅仅花五分钟坐在外面，感受微风拂面，或者花时间倾听鸟儿的鸣叫、周围的对话或环境噪音，只是
experiencing your breath as it goes in or out. That experience of solitude, however it comes, can be extraordinarily powerful and calming. One of my favorite ways to experience solitude is through gratitude practice as well. To take five minutes and just to remember three things that we're grateful for can be a very simple but powerful way to again re-encrease. So in this time of great upheaval, I think it's more important than ever that we find time for that solitude. And the key here is that a little bit of time can go a long way.
体验呼吸的进出。这种独处体验，无论以何种方式到来，都可以是异常强大和令人平静的。体验独处的我最喜欢的方式之一也是通过感恩练习。花五分钟时间，仅仅回想三件我们感激的事情，就可以成为一种非常简单但强大的方式来重新锚定。因此，在这个动荡的时代，我认为寻找独处时间比以往任何时候都更加重要。这里的关键是，一小段时间就能发挥巨大作用。
It's not about spending an hour in mindfulness practice. This is about spending a few high-quality minutes allowing ourselves to just be. There have been scholars who have pointed out that the term social distancing is actually a bad phrase because what you need to combat a pandemic is physical distancing, not social distancing. Can you talk a little bit about how you and your friends have created virtual circles for yourselves based on the ideas from a Japanese tradition. Yes, I agree that the term social distancing is a misnomer. What we're seeking to do is to physically distance people, but what happens to our social
这不是花一个小时进行正念练习。这是关于花几分钟高质量的时间，允许自己只是存在。有一些学者指出，“社交距离”这个术语其实是个糟糕的词，因为对抗大流行你需要的是物理距离，而不是社交距离。你能谈谈你和你的朋友是如何根据日本传统的理念，为自己创建虚拟圈子的吗？是的，我同意“社交距离”这个词是个用词不当。我们寻求做到的是拉开人们之间的物理距离，但我们的社交
connection is up to us, whether it weakens as a result of reduced physical contact or whether we intentionally find ways to strengthen it as a decision that is in our hands to make. A few years ago, two friends of mine, Sunny and Dave, were at a retreat in Colorado Springs, and these are two dear friends of mine who I love seeing, but I don't get to see them nearly as often as I want. And as we were walking around the lake, we said, gosh, wouldn't it be great if we could see each other more often?
连接会发生什么取决于我们，是会因为物理接触减少而减弱，还是我们有意寻找方法来加强它，这是我们自己手中可以做出的决定。几年前，我的两个朋友桑尼和戴夫在科罗拉多斯普林斯的一个静修营，这是我非常珍视的两位朋友，我喜欢见他们，但却不能像我希望的那样经常见到他们。当我们绕着湖散步时，我们说，天哪，如果我们能更常见面，那该多好啊？
We were all three at inflection points in our life. We were struggling with career decisions. We were all recently married, and we're trying to figure out how to balance life. And to some extent, we were also all struggling with loneliness and lack of community. But at the end of that walk, we realized unless we did something differently, that we simply just couldn't wish
我们三人当时都处于人生的拐点。我们都在为职业决策苦苦挣扎。我们都是最近才结婚，正试图弄清楚如何平衡生活。在某种程度上，我们也都在与孤独和缺乏社群感作斗争。但在那次散步结束时，我们意识到，除非我们做出不同的改变，否则我们简直无法奢望
that more opportunities for meeting up would come about. So we made a pact at the end of that walk. We said once a month, we are gonna video conference for two hours. And during those two hours, we're gonna be honest and open with each other about what we're going through. That sure we're gonna have hours, we're gonna be honest and open with each other about what we're going through, that sure we're gonna have fun, we're gonna catch up,
会有更多相聚的机会出现。所以在散步结束时，我们立下了一个契约。我们说，一个月一次，我们要进行两个小时的视频会议。在那两个小时里，我们要彼此诚实和坦诚地交流我们正在经历的事情，当然我们要有时间去享受乐趣，去叙旧，
but we're also gonna talk about the hard things that friends don't talk to each other about often enough, we're gonna talk about our health, about our relationships, about our finances. And we also made a commitment that in between those calls, that if we needed support, or we were confused about a big decision that we had to make, or we were just feeling lost, that we'd reach out, that we would text each other.
但我们也要谈论那些朋友之间往往不够常谈的艰难事情，我们要谈论我们的健康，我们的关系，我们的财务状况。我们还做出承诺，在这些通话之间，如果我们需要支持，或者对必须做出的大重大决定感到困惑，或者只是感到迷失，我们会主动联系，我们会给彼此发信息。
And if we needed to, we'd get on an ad hoc call, and just, even if it was for five minutes, just talk to each other and hear each other's voices. Over the next few months, those calls became my lifeline. They became the backbone of my journey from disconnection back to connection. Now, I had felt always deeply loved and connected to my wife Alice and to our two small children. But what I realized I was missing, even though I had these beautiful intimate connections, you know, with my parents, my sister, and Alice and the kids,
如果需要，我们会进行临时通话，即使只有五分钟，也要和彼此交谈，听到彼此的声音。在接下来的几个月里，这些电话成了我的救命稻草。它们成了我从失联走向重新连接的脊梁。现在，我一直深深地爱着我的妻子爱丽丝和我们的两个小孩，并与他们保持着连接。但我意识到自己所缺少的，尽管我有这些美好的亲密连接（你知道的，与我的父母、姐姐、爱丽丝和孩子们的连接），
is I was missing those relational connections and those collective connections. And that was a big part of what Sunny and Dave gave me. And so we maintain that practice. We think of ourselves as a MOI, which is an ancient Japanese tradition for bringing people together in the old times from a very, very early age, where they would be connected and committed to each other, and they would see each other
是我缺少了那些关系连接和群体连接。这是桑尼和戴夫带给我的很大一部分东西。所以我们保持了这种做法。我们将自己视为一个“讲（Moai）”，这是一个古老的日本传统，用于自非常非常早的时期起将人们聚集在旧时光里，在那里他们彼此连接并承诺，无论发生什么，他们都会
through difficult times, whatever came. And that's what Sunny and Dave have done for me, and I'm deeply grateful for it. One of the ideas you talk about is how if you want to feel more connected to others, the best thing to do might not be to ask why others are not reaching out to you, but ask how you can be of service to others. And there certainly have been leaders like Martin Luther King Jr. and Mahatma Gandhi who have talked about this idea that service in some ways can be an antidote to loneliness. Can you talk about this idea of a vague? Absolutely. This was one of the most powerful lessons that I learned,
度过艰难困苦。这就是桑尼和戴夫为我所做的，对此我深表感激。你谈到的观点之一是，如果你想感受到与他人更多的连接，最好的做法可能不是去问为什么别人没有联系你，而是去问你能如何为他人服务。当然也有过像小马丁·路德·金和圣雄甘地这样的领袖谈论过这个观点，即在某些方面服务可以成为孤独的解药。你能谈谈这个关于维韦克的观点吗？绝对可以。这是我学到的最强大的教训之一，
which is that service is one of the most powerful solutions when it comes to loneliness. It is a natural and highly effective way of connecting with other people. And to understand that, you've done, you've the biology of loneliness makes us turn our focus inward, and it also leads to a general chipping away of our self-esteem over time as we come to believe that we're lonely because we're not likeable. But what service does, which is so powerful, is it shifts the focus from us to someone else in the context of a positive experience. And it also reaffirms for us that we have value to bring to the world and to somebody else's life. And that can be extraordinarily powerful in breaking that downward spiral of loneliness,
那就是服务是解决孤独问题最强大的解决方案之一。这是与他人连接的一种自然且高效的方式。为了理解这一点，孤独的生物学让我们把焦点转向内，随着时间的推移，它还会导致我们自尊心的普遍侵蚀，因为我们开始相信我们感到孤独是因为我们不可爱。但服务所做的（这是如此强大）是将焦点从我们身上转移到积极体验背景下的另一个人身上。它还向我们重申，我们拥有带给世界和他人生命的价值。这在打破孤独的恶性循环方面可能是异常强大的，
which is so dangerous. If we look around us, we'll find that there are many ways in which we can serve. Serving isn't always volunteering at a soup kitchen or volunteering to build homes with habitat for humanity as powerful as those methods of serving are. But service can also be calling a friend who you know may be struggling to balance work and kids and could use a pick me up or could just use the knowledge that somebody has looking out for them. Service can be checking on a neighbor who might be elderly and struggling. Service can be helping a colleague at work who might be having a tough day just bringing them a coffee or stopping to say, hey, I want to know how you're doing and then actually pausing to listen to what they have to say, hey, I want to know how you're doing and then actually pausing to listen to what they have to say.
这是非常危险的。如果我们环顾四周，我们会发现有很多我们可以服务的方式。服务并不总是去流浪收容所做志愿者，或者和仁人家园一起做志愿者去盖房子，尽管那些服务方法同样强大。但服务也可以是给一个你知道可能在平衡工作和孩子方面苦苦挣扎、需要打气或者只需要知道有人在关照他们的朋友打个电话。服务可以是查看一位可能年迈且在苦苦挣扎的邻居。服务可以是在工作帮助一个可能正经历艰难一天的同事，只是给他们带杯咖啡，或者停下来对他们说，嘿，我想知道你过得怎么样，然后真正停下来倾听他们要说的话。
And one of the greatest gifts that we can give another person is the gift of our full attention. And often when we think about serving, we think, well, what can I tell somebody to help and fix something? What can I do to change a problem in their life. But we often forget that simply showing up and listening can be an extraordinarily powerful experience. If you've ever felt deeply listened to by somebody else, you know that that experience helps you feel seen and appreciate it and understood. And that is a very, very powerful antidote to loneliness and to disconnection. So as we think about how to serve, I suspect that if we look around us that we'll find many opportunities to do so and we'll recognize that all we need to bring to those opportunities to serve are an open mind, a full heart, and a desire to truly, honestly
我们能给予另一个人的最大礼物之一就是我们的全部注意力。通常，当我们考虑服务时，我们会想，嗯，我能对某人说些什么来帮助和解决问题？我能做些什么来改变他们生活中的一个问题。但我们常常忘记，仅仅出现并倾听就可以是一种异常强大的体验。如果你曾被某人深深地倾听过，你就会知道那种体验能帮助你感受到被看见、被欣赏和被理解。这是对抗孤独和失联的一种非常非常强大的解药。因此，当我们思考如何服务时，我猜如果我们环顾四周，我们会发现许多这样做的机会，并且我们会认识到，我们需要带给这些服务机会的全部就是开放的心态、饱满的心灵，以及真正、诚实地
and openly connect with another human being. Vivek Morthy served as the 19th Surgeon General of the United States. He is the author of the book, Together, the healing power of human connection in a sometimes lonely world. Vivek, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much, anchor. This week's show was produced by Path Shah, edited by Tara Boyle and Raina Cohen, technical support from Andy Huthar. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Thomas Liu, Laura Quarell,
和公开地与另一个人连接的渴望。维韦克·穆尔蒂曾任美国第19任外科医生总长。他是《在一起：有时孤独的世界中人类连接的治愈力量》一书的作者。维韦克，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢你，山卡尔。本周的节目由帕斯·沙阿制作，塔拉·博伊尔和雷娜·科恩编辑，安迪·胡萨尔提供技术支持。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特、刘托马斯、劳拉·夸雷尔、
Kat Schuchnick and Lushik Waba. If you want to hear more about the topic of loneliness, be sure to check out an earlier episode of Hidden Brain titled The Lonely American Man. One challenge in producing our show from home is trying to replicate the sound of NPR studios. This can be challenging because our guests are also often at home. Often the burden of creating a quiet recording space falls on their families.
卡特·舒奇尼克和鲁希克·瓦巴。如果你想听更多关于孤独话题的内容，请务必查看《隐藏的大脑》早期的一集，名为《孤独的美国男人》。从家中制作我们节目的一个挑战是试图复制NPR工作室的声音。这可能具有挑战性，因为我们的嘉宾也经常在家。营造安静录音空间的负担往往落在了他们的家人身上。
That's why this week's unsung hero is Vivek's sister, Dr. Rashmi Muthi. She facilitated our interview by keeping Vivek's kids occupied while he chatted with me. Babu, come, we have to go. Come here, come here, come here. What? Papa's recording. Oh, boy. I can't even, I can't be upstairs.
这就是为什么本周的无名英雄是维韦克的姐姐拉什米·穆尔蒂博士。当维韦克和我聊天时，她通过照看维韦克的孩子来促成我们的采访。巴布，来，我们得走了。过来，过来，过来。什么？爸爸在录音。哦，天哪。我甚至不能，我不能去楼上。
Thank you, Rashmi, for allowing us to turn your home into a temporary recording studio. We really appreciate it. Come, let's do, let's do P.P. and then I'll give you some ice cream. Come. What is the podcast over? For more hidden brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If this episode spoke to you, please be sure to share it with a friend. I'm Shankar Vedantum and this is NPR.
谢谢你，拉什米，允许我们把你的家变成临时录音室。我们真的很感激。来，我们做，我们做P.P.然后我给你冰淇淋。来。播客结束了吗？有关更多《隐藏的大脑》内容，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。如果这一集对你有所触动，请务必与朋友分享。我是山卡尔·维达antam，这里是NPR。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你 这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。